alyssa is playing a video game her
character is on a quest to vanquish an
evil sorcerer and his minions from the
land her character is a wizard who
spells have a range of 6 meters the
locations of objects in the game are
stored by the computer in terms of x and
y-coordinates so 5 comma 4 is the
location of Alyssa's wizard 8 , 7 is the
location of minion a 2 comma negative 1
is the location of minion B 9 common
comma 0 is location of minion C so what
I wanted to do and I want you to pause
this video and I want to think about
given that her wizard has a range of 6
meters which of these minions can the
wizard actually reach I'm assuming
you've given a go at it we just have to
remind ourselves we're to figure out
which of these minions are in reach we
to say well which of these points are
within 6 units we're assuming that these
units are in meters right over here
which of these points are within six
units of 5 comma 4 and to think about
that we just have to calculate the
distance between this point and this
point that point and that point that
point in that point and see if they are
greater than or less than 6 meters and
how do we calculate a distance between
two points well if this is some point
right over here that's x1 comma y1 and
then this is another point right over
here x2 comma y2 and we want to
calculate this distance right over here
the distance formula comes straight out
of the Pythagorean theorem it's the
Pythagorean theorem tells us if this
side right over here is our change in Y
and that let's actually just write that
as the absolute value of our change in Y
and let's say that this side right over
here is the absolute value of our change
in X absolute value of our change in X
the fact Pythagorean theorem tells us
that this one the hypotenuse is going to
be the square root of the sum of the
squares of the two sides so change in x
squared plus change in Y squared plus
change in Y squared you might say hey
what happened to the absolute value well
when I square it it's going to be
positive anyway so I don't have to write
down
the absolute value so really I just need
to figure out between each of these two
points what is the change in X what's
the change in Y square them add them
together and then take the square root
so for example let's find let's find so
if I were to call this if I were to call
this pp1 if I were to call this p2 we
call this p3 or do them in different
colors so you can keep track of what I'm
doing this is p3 and let's say this is
p4 so let's first think about the
distance the distance between p1 and p2
and p2 well that's going to be equal to
the square root of our change in x
squared so our change in X is 3 that
squared is 9 plus our change in Y
squared our change in Y is also 3 that
squared is 9 so this is going to be
square root of 18 which is the same
thing as 3 square roots of 2 3 square
roots of 2 now is this more or less than
6 well 3 times 2 is equal to 6 square
root of 2 is less than 2 it's one point
something it's 1 so this right over here
is going to be this over here is going
to be less than 6 so p2 is in range
Alissa's Wizard can get minion a minion
a she can attack now let's think about
minion B so the distance between P 1 and
P 3 and P 3 is going to be equal to the
square root of so your change in X it's
negative 3 negative 3 squared is
positive 9 our change in Y to go from 4
to negative 1 it's negative 5 that
squared is 25 so 9 plus 25 which is
equal to the square root of 34 now is
this greater than or equal to 6
well 34 30
square root of 36 is 6 so this is going
to this is a square root of a lower
number so this is going to be less than
6 as well so P minion B is also in reach
now let's think about this last point
the distance the distance between P 1
and P 4 and P 4 is going to be equal to
the square root of our change in x
squared change in X is 4 squared is 16
plus our change in Y squared our change
in Y is negative 4 but you square that
you get another 16 so this is going to
be square root of 32 which could be
written out actually we could just leave
it as square root of 32 square root of
32 is clearly less than the square root
of 36 which is 6 so this is also going
to be less than 6 so she can get at all
of the minions she can get at all of the
minions they're all within six units of
her now which of these is the furthest
away well actually if we were to write
this we simplified this but we could
write this as a square root of 18 square
root of 18 is clearly the smallest out
of square root of 18 square root of 32
and square root of 34 so minion minion a
is the closest and minion B square root
of 34 is the farthest or I should say
the farthest is is the farthest